it's been 20 years since I wiped the
floor
tell me what you were thinking right at
the moment that they called my name oh
you know this you look at me and you
said look at the two of us can you
believe the least likely people to be
here and here we are and then right
after you said that I turned to my left
and Ryan was going through his cards and
I saw the card that had your name on it
if you watch I'm actually staring right
at you right your name was when your
name was you're like no you were doing
hey bro I knew what was going to happen
and I kind of just wanted to see the
look on your face actually I remember
you saying it's you before he said you
did before he even said my name
enjoy this moment